[Music]
nostalgia critic critic of nostalgia
searching for a movie to tap into the
inner frustrations every movie nerd has
then a feeling of a fascinatingly
misdirected movie alters his chemistry
and now whenever he hears any mention of
the movie hope a startling metamorphosis
occurs
Malcolm Tamara do not show me that booth
you wouldn't like me when you show me
that move
[Music]
the critic is wanted for property damage
he didn't commit
well okay he did but was just of a movie
and that movie sucked
the critics patience is believed to be
dead and he must let the world believe
it is dead until he can find a way to
control the whiny bitch Fitz that dwells
within him
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to you
know they should be the easiest guy to
make interesting The Incredible Hulk is
a classic Jekyll and Hyde story about
scientist Bruce Banner whose experiment
goes wrong and turns into a giant green
monster whenever he gets angry it has
both the psychological and physical
elements that usually make for great
classic storytelling yet his cinematic
ventures have been so underwhelming that
despite him being many people's favorite
parts in other movies no solo movies are
planned in the near future and that all
started with a huh simply known as Hulk
[Music]
how can a story about a giant green
monster be boring that was the challenge
presumably given to director Angley he
just finished a winning streak with his
martial arts opus crunching tiger in
dragon winning over box office critics
and too many awards to count so
producers immediately said that we want
that far action-packed Hulk movie but
what they were missing is that angly
usually did social dramas he did
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon because he
always wanted to do a martial arts movie
won one martial arts movie he brushed up
four years of martial arts lake so he
could figure out how to do it right with
Hulk very clearly he was a director for
hire and saw this more as a means to
experiment rather than bring a lifelong
dream to life and much like Bruce Banner
this experiment would haunt him for the
rest of his days
he certainly recovered and returned back
to his comfort zone but the mark this
movie left on comic fans is probably the
most uniquely bad since this this is why
Superman works alone but while that was
bright and colorful and at least made
little kids happy this would only make
that kid who stands in the corner saying
I'm bad I'm bad I'm bad happy because
he's gonna set someone on fire so why is
this the most intriguing and yet somehow
also most boring of missteps well let's
make everybody angry with Hulk
[Music]
well toned down those expectations there
this is not the movie you're going to
get no let's instead do those early
two-thousands credits of blurry closest
mixed with sped up and slowed down
editing I've always wanted to see an
intro with my glasses off and a monkey
playing with the remote ok Coco push
play play play no now your best morning
no now you're throwing it down no now
you have it down extreme zoom experience
another pull back to normal this is the
best way to watch this movie oh if you
think this style is only done in the
credits your senses are in from
bludgeoning because there's gimmicky
editing techniques throughout the entire
film and I mean the entire film just
look at this flashback of Bruce banners
father
[Music]
if you find this mildly annoying then
just add two hours of it in that M will
quickly turn upside down like me you
might be wondering what's the point of
all these transition tricks tricks ish
ins as I like to call them my best guess
is Angley wanted to create the closest
thing he could to a comic book meaning
the film literally has panels B lines
and elements of space and time
overlapping each other there's just one
problem with that though if you're
adapting a book would you constantly put
words all over the goddamn place
this is way too freaking lateral there's
two problems with this technique in a
comic book these are used to suck you
more into the story it leaps off the
page and brings you into their reality
this is constantly taking you out of
what's going on
you can't ever breathe in the world
because the movies too busy trying to
physically show you the lines that
they're supposed to be breathing in
there's three problems with this I'm
sorry to dwell on this so much but this
is literally throughout the whole
goddamn film it's best to tackle it and
what other movies like spider-man and
Sin City look like the comics they
portrayed to create a stronger
environment for the world they're
adventurous they're action-packed
they're totally over-the-top you know
what this film mostly consists of
we're passing inspection safeties all
going green bat a lot of sitting around
and talking so the style doesn't even
match the tone it's like they've
realized there's no friggin excitement
in this lake so to remind you it's even
supposed to be a comic book film they're
like um
throw some comics ads in there put that
frame there that frame over there and
make it look like the Brady Bunch
comics we get this and second thought
maybe we don't where the hell is there a
comic that had imagery like that
maybe if I read it while doing it is
also I don't think trees are a big focus
of comics we're really putting the
camera on this weird this board this
early unless is such reboots pornstache
why are you shooting that so something
tragic happens in Bruce's past that he's
repressed and with his dad taking his
mother screaming into the back you can
probably guess what it is
Oh I mean I'm gonna spend the whole
entire film wondering what that Beach
Hills his mom come on
it even cuts immediately to a foster
home when he's a teen you think we
couldn't figure this out
though to the credit maybe his debt
mom's disinterest is supposed to
distract us from connecting the dots
there's something inside you so special
some kind of greatness I'm sure and
someday you're gonna share it with the
whole world okay cut that was good but
let's try something a little different
here this time let's try trying don't
don't worry stepmother the award for at
least of my effort clearly goes to
Jennifer Connelly I get the feeling
every day she showed up to the set and
the crew was like okay Connelly uh are
we gonna act today or not act today
there's some sort of explosion they
wouldn't let us into the building I was
worried about you not act today okay
it's not acting that everybody we just
want to know how to shoot it to make you
look invested help I think the most
gripping performances and the movie
probably come from these to security or
to be beefed up a lot more in a place
like this I really believed he wanted
tighter security and I really believe
that Lou Ferrigno was um looking at him
okay I didn't even believe that but he
looked like this for years he gets a
pass by the way - two points for even
your credits not being consistent when
even your font doesn't know what it
wants to be you're kind of in trouble
Bruce hey justly we find out that Bruce
played by Eric Bana is working on ways
to expose gamma rays to electro energy
gigawatts capacitor science II shit were
somehow superpowers are the wrong answer
they try their experiment on a frog and
discover the results are a little too
explosive
[Music]
somebody called Miss Piggy there's been
an accident
want to go to the review board on Monday
and tell them what about the brand new
method for exploding frogs yeah I think
maybe there's a market for it
frog start falling from the sky who do
they come to oh ha ha ha ha ha no really
suck it in while you can that's the only
joke in the entire movie excuse me
there's a bookmark of a man reading
fighting for space ok if you really
can't draw this much attention to your
transitions I'm gonna drive him more
attention to it by putting in the goofy
sound effects they deserve this dickface
mcsneer smirk is Glen he's do exactly
what you think he's gonna do try and
steal banners girlfriend get in the way
of his experiment and waste a lot of
time trying to explain every boring
reason why snow house business what do
you want your little molecular machines
have some incredible implications how'd
you like to come work for a Theon get
paid 10 times as much as you are now
people calmly discussing things staring
at each other in silence but look green
walls it's kind of like the Hulk is
there symbolically oh you just don't get
it you don't understand the layers of
subtlety and conversation that need to
be had with
oh look it's the film's first big
surprise they got a new janitor hey what
up Benny see not working the night shift
anymore I'm the new guy
that's exciting it's me Sam
ah the classic mop transition I see so
often in comics that's a good thing
nobody takes a shit in this movie
so Bruce sits around staring at old
pictures of Connolly as his girlfriend
oh come on
even the Kodak film has to run through
the pretentious filter just waiting for
the prisoner of azkaban to knock him out
with a bottle of butter beer this
results in a flashback of when Bruce and
her were still dating you tell me about
your dream starts with a memory from
when I was maybe two years old I was
living at a desert base with my father
suddenly I'm alone
[Music]
talking about dreams reoccurring dreams
with your boyfriend being your father
and trying to strangle you put before
you what that's terrible never hurt you
okay um anyone that's new to the dating
scene I don't know what Angley is trying
to tell you but if your date says they
have a reoccurring dream about you as
their father trying to kill them as a
small child out to get out going to make
up an excuse flee the only person you
should flee faster from is McNulty of
course he's in this movie may not want
to believe it Nolte plays banners real
dad I'm not sure if you went crazy and
then did the film or if he did the film
and then went crazy but there's regret
to be had all around I guess he's
supposed to be intimidating but it
doesn't really help when you're stalking
a guy with three cuddly dogs by your
side no seriously this was supposed to
be a threatening image I'm sorry
the dogs goddamn ruin it Panther is so
intimidated by this that he actually
closes the blinds why even the most
paranoid person would muster a sweat
from this
[Laughter]
hey buddy Best in Show is down the
street what are you gonna break out the
baton and have them Park ode to joy' oh
I thought I was gonna dive laughter oh
they really need to be in a Hulk movie
Bruce walks in to find smooth suit McGee
yeah who wants to weaponize his ability
to blow up frogs about Glenn I am
there's nothing to talk about
oh good bang Jesus were a half-hour in
and that only has no action happen but
think about it what do we really know
about Bruce Banner he fondles babies and
other people's dreams well that's the
most I'm getting out of it oh no
something's happening it stopped before
these two the dangers of interest the
experiment seems to go wonky and Bruce
sacrifices himself to a Photoshop filter
no really it's this one see finally
leading to him transforming into a guy
in a hospital bed oh my god he's all
right
how's Harper he's all right we're gonna
sell so many toys her name is not
concealer but hospital security is
proofing it's worth every penny as Nick
Nolte and his presumably extended family
sneak in to see Bruce then a terrible
accident
sir perhaps you shouldn't leave we're
gonna have to watch that temper of yours
yes lord knows this really seems like a
guy who flies off the handle what we
watch it
that thing whisperer almost turned into
a Talwar Connally agrees to meet with
our father played by Sam Elliot whoa car
sorry this movie so don't lie confuse
that for an action sequence who is also
interested in their scientific
discoveries look I'm gonna get right to
it just cringe where you work with you
know who he really is how much do you
actually know about him you ever notice
how Sam Elliot talks like he has one
last bite a steak in his mouth all right
now I'm at liberty to look I'm
but notice shoo and swallow it makes you
and swallow its root act with your mouth
full don't make more of a waste you in
another movie maybe this time you just
honestly wanted to see me again I do
want to see you I really wish that I
could the teaser that literally looks
like this
was literally representing this hog the
fight thing is we're about 45 minutes in
well okay I guess they're doing the jaws
effect and trying to build up the green
guy's appearance but here's the thing
when he does finally change it happens
right the hell out of nowhere yeah he's
just sitting at his computer doing work
and suddenly he's like shit dammit I
want the Hulk there's only so long we
can pretend we know what we're talking
about deliver the green M&Ms records
yeah that's great that's great we've
waited 45 minutes to see this damn thing
please focus on the beaker that is
clearly what we want to look at you know
what Roz did show up they didn't focus
on the life preserver okay she's here
Christ we finally got him that friggin
long last
here is the Hulk get him the hell out of
here we got changing back as fast as
possible for more boring conversations
who are you with the lab there was that
man oh that new janitor the dog's grace
I can't take the same where I need a
break here's some people that know how
to sell something fun better than this
goddamn movie
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey kids you want something smashing
will crash your way to excitement with
the Hulk
now that you have everyone's favorite
crushing machine what are you gonna do
with him I'm gonna think about the
repressed memories that might be hiding
in my psyche okay hey little girl what
are you going to do with him I'm getting
you some as justification to finally
confront my domineering father melody
that's so brave of you thank you
well doesn't anyone want to use them for
smashing and stopping the forces of evil
Shh did you see he's distracted I can't
believe we're losing the grant money
it's okay cliff we'll think of something
will we or will we be lost to the visual
representation of our own subconscious
[Music]
the huh it's as much fun as it looks
done with childish things
[Music]
so as mentioned before connelly visits
to explain what happened last night it
was like being born reacting by not
reacting done but it looks like Elliott
thinks Bruce might be behind the lab
being destroyed we have no idea where
your father is saying ma'am can you help
us
Mitchell escort my daughter outside I'll
join her shortly chew and swallow
Connolly goes to Nick Nolte's house film
presumably on location at Nick Nolte's
house as she discovers he's Bruce's
father and they have a competition for
who can speak the softest jamb changing
he seems to think he's involved in some
kind of threat to national security
my son is unique he was born without a
personality
actually that's not very unique in this
movie you make the fleas and my beard go
crazy besides he was made clear he wants
nothing to do with me yeah I can clearly
see that you took my scarf as displayed
by this shot of me clearly seeing you
taking my scarf today I'm not asking for
it back
director I mean you focused on it you
actually showed a scene of me seeing him
take it
I'm not retrieving what was touched by
Nick Nolte's dirty diseased fill hands
you know what he can keep it he uses the
scarf to give her scent to the beast
from Sam lot as cops around banders
house keeping him under house arrest
that's how I learned doing a bang-up job
as you can see
oh no the cops you call the cops how
dare you make me feel an emotion in this
film mr. giant he makes his way to
Connolly's house whose reaction is
exactly how it is in the rest of the
film
[Music]
cart ok Conaway let's try something a
little different here on act got a bob I
would have gone through at least the
majority of the Three Stooges reactions
at this point tarantula oh but for some
reason you thought that didn't deserve a
big reaction how about this coughing
guys come on yep this is the first
action sequence in the movie one hour in
and he's fighting mutant pound puppies
it's been this always what you wanted
when you saw the Incredible Hulk on TV
and cartoons and in the comics weren't
you always wishing for the big screen
adaptation where he fought the zombie
cast of Lady and the Tramp
you just know Stanley was watching the
dailies of this and was like Tiger
Hidden Dragon
so the Hulk defeats the mutant poodle
something I didn't think I'd say while
watching this and changes back because
by God we haven't seen enough of him as
a normal guy yet have we well I believe
the scientific term is ridiculous so but
Ilya tranquilizes him it takes him to
his jokes where he keeps him out tonight
much to his daughter's dismay he saved
my life yeah from a mutant French poodle
I'm indebted to him for that
you know Sam he almost made that stupid
line work but you didn't you still had
to say the words mutant French poodle
but it was a good try no experiments on
himself try to continue beautiful work
allowing him to physically adapt to his
surroundings this in all honesty leads
to maybe the only cool scene in the
movie
cat dammit why that Cool Hand have to be
attached to dignity and wine that nick
nolte had to be attached to this film
don't worry though they give you more of
exactly what you came here for friggin
talking only this time there's an army
to stop any exciting developments so
there's no fear of that pesky joy hell I
think even the soldiers will be shouting
at them to get some action about now
it's hard to believe we used to live
here I must have seen you or known you
only I could remember oh my god
tell them the movies gonna bawl Tommy's
gonna be replaced by two actors - this
is my house isn't it you know you see
that unused playground equipment that's
supposed to be fun for kids but is in
the middle of an empty lifeless
wasteland I can't help but wonder if
that's angry symbolic cry for help
to have a good nap how dare you wake me
up I was having the most wonderful dream
where I wasn't watching you
so Glen's eggs over the operation so he
can weaponize the Holts DNA but while
studying him Bruce dives deep into his
repressed memories and figures out the
painful truth and that it was so painful
how much we already knew the truth
Bruce's dad killed his mom you can bear
fine now here's another big surprise
I think that's Wonder Woman if course
turns into the human battle toad and he
tries busting his way out but they have
phone to stop him because if it makes
bath time fun surely it can make the
hole fun okay I think this scene only
exists just to make a caption contest
like name this movie and give only wrong
answers or explain how this is somehow
the way we first met or this is what we
spend 137 million dollars on guys
wait cray cray
Wow even by this movie's standards that
was a new level of what coming summer
1977 a spin-off of Charlie's Angels
entitled guide flying over fireball
looking like a twat
[Music]
Eliott does the sensible thing of
releasing him on to the world and the
military tries to take him down in the
desert to hell with this interpretive
dance bullshit I gotta smash something
okay I know the Hulk is supposed to be
able to jump far but the way they do it
he looks like an unrendered Mario
character and we finally get a little
bit of Hulk actually fighting someone
[Music]
we're just gonna hold on the shot until
you realize that looks like penis got it
good
[Music]
but he makes his way to San Francisco
presumably to stop more seasons of
fuller house we then interrupt this
thrilling action sequence to give you
shaving was every scene based on a bet
hey I bet you can't do a Hulk movie
where he fights a poodle hey I bet you
can't do a Hulk movie where you stop
like bath products yeah but you can't do
a Hulk movie where he shaves in the
middle of a fight sequence whoa whoa
hang on that just try one of those bets
in the movie I didn't know you do all
three oh my god there should be a
diffuse manual for the bomb you're
making yeah of course keeps going and
makes it to the city alright now it's
time to do some real damage
go rampage before rampage MUX it up or
in keeping on track stop before you get
to the actual cool stuff that works not
at all
Selin LT is brought to his son which
obviously means the movie should focus
on the conflict between Nolte and Elliot
maybe they had a competition for who
could be understood the least he's
brought in to apparently take part in
the stage play version of the film for
us what's your favorite word sorry face
but hey let's have this two hours suck
go out on a high note
eze multi gives his best impression of
Yosemite Sam swallowing a duck I don't
think he could shoe more scenery than if
he literally picked up the set and
started biting it somebody should
actually stop him before he eats himself
he absorbs the electricity making him
super powerful and I'm just gonna take a
wild guess and say Connolly stares
blankly at this
I never thought I'd say this but can we
have this performance back someone has
been in my room again I hate that I
can't promise it won't lead to this but
at least it's an attempt banner turns
into the Hulk and ulti flies them away
absorbing whatever he touches it's the
ultimate battle between father and son
even though there's surprisingly been
very little time dedicated to them
interacting as father and son so much
has not been building up to this hey we
may be bad but we're not fan force dead
yet
[Music]
oh my god is the audience patients it's
about to blow but the army newts them
and they're both presumed dead Connelly
cares so little that she's lost her true
love that she actually consoles her
father rather than her father consoling
her when will I be more considerate
about how my lack of feelings affects
your feelings but of course they can't
shake this feeling that banner is still
alive if by some chance he get in touch
I know he's still out there
Bruce taking it easy for us sinners yeah
it looks like he is still out there
using his research to help others until
somebody tries to stop him exciting
looking credits that in no way reflect
the joyless mess that we just witnessed
somebody's terrible it's the perfect
definition of misguided it has some neat
ideas the visuals don't even argue that
one or two of those transitions could be
very effective clever beautiful at times
but there's just no thrill or investment
banner is not made an interesting
character he's forgettable and bland
just like the rest of the characters and
when you can't find them interesting you
can't find the film interesting plain
and simple I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
I need to journey to find better movies
to watch
[Music]
you
saved my life yeah from a mutant French
poodle
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shot on this week I'm doing a fam
request this is for the rain forest
foundation the rain forest foundation
was founded on a new idea what the
indigenous people of the rainforest had
the legal right to protect the forest we
all depend on for a long time
environmental organizations didn't focus
on human rights in fact people were
usually seen as part of the problem but
this foundation listened to the
indigenous communities living deep in
the Brazilian Amazon and decided to put
their might behind fighting to protect
the rainforest lands just as they always
had today we know that rainforest
protected by indigenous communities have
the lower rates of deforestation than
any other forests in the world including
national parks national preserves
government land and private sanctuaries
so yes rainforests can also be the homes
to many many people and we want to keep
it that way if you look at their site
and their YouTube channel you can see
all the people who benefit from the
wonders of these incredible forms you
can see how they live how they thrive
and how they want to continue to do so
help protect these people and their
homes click on the link and see how you
can be a big part of the solution
you